the path just it's got it's a new season
it's very exciting and we actually have
one of the ads for the new season of the
path and you're lying there with what is
that a that is a snake well I know it's
a snake how insulting of you incredibly
insulting of you I just didn't know if
they put in a fake snake or is that a
real song a real snake his name is ghost
that's the snake we actually used in the
show has a big part of the second season
I [ __ ] all over me all the time what are
you talking about that snake they
constantly put on me especially that day
it was just like to go to the bathroom
uh me all the time yeah I don't even
think it's so stupid of me to say but I
don't think of snakes going to the
bathroom go to the bathroom yeah think
about they do they don't go to the
bathroom they just [ __ ] yeah
[Applause]
excuse me where's the little snakes it
has a terrible smell it's white it's
just it's nasty yeah yeah
so and I forget I have this really
embarrassing gag reflex if something
disgusting happens in front of me I just
start oh right yeah yeah oh you do you
have that thing yeah some people have
that it's not this man I can't I can't
control I was doing I was doing this
movie years ago Exodus where Christian
Bale and myself were parting the Red Sea
mm-hmm and all the camels and all the
horses were so terrified by the current
that this row of jet skis was closed how
did the effectors with jet ski that with
jet skis there's like a row of 20 jet
skis just full blast causing this
current and the camels and horses were
just [ __ ] all over the place yeah
and we're shooting this like little cove
for two solid days it was a toilet bowl
I mean it was disgusting is there any
time we would say cut I'm walking back
with the horses and I'm just dry heaving
and Christians just laughing at me it's
great it means to realize what Moses
really went through right yeah he was
there with a bunch of animals yeah there
was he in this just this foul some it
gives you new even greater respect
respects in the man yeah until glamorous
life yeah
you